throughout the course we've been
mentioning how crucial it is for
startups to keep iterating in learning
in this lesson we're going to explore
how to choose the right metrics to
measure your marketing goals and how to
track them each case will be different
but there are a few things you can
consider when choosing the metrics to
follow you're going to learn how to
validate and optimize your marketing
efforts through experimentation we'll
talk about how to run marketing
experiments and iterate based on the
results you receive and finally on top
of analyzing the what we will research
also the why and learn how to run
experiments with real users using your
app